good morning John it's Tuesday September
14th and alright and hours from the
nearest internet connection
[Music]
I am visiting my great aunt and uncle in
law Joyce in Irving in the middle of
nowhere Maine I mean Montana is one
thing but we have like movie theaters
and art galleries and demolition derbies
and coffee shops with internet in them
this place has indoor plumbing and hot
water but that's about as far as it goes
though I'll tell you my phone gets
amazing reception here way better than
we ever get in Montana but my phone does
not have 3G it is not a smart phone my
phone is dumb my phone is so dumb and I
would put a joke here if I had the
internet to look up jokes I am NOT funny
without the Internet actually whenever I
spend a lot of time without what was
that thought maybe there was a snake or
something actually whenever I spend a
lot of time without the internet I end
up with colossal amounts of brain crack
I guess what I'm not doing stuff I tend
to spend a lot more time thinking about
stuff to do so here are my two brain
crack ideas from so far this trip one
building vending machines two busses so
that when you're on the Greyhound bus or
city bus you can get like a Coke or a
sandwich because I'm always hungry and
thirsty on buses or two housed camera
that you can like clamp to a tree or a
pole or something that takes time lapse
pictures of whatever you want to take
time like pictures ups you just screw it
in turn it on and then come back in a
year when whatever you wanted to take
the time-lapse movie of is done doing
its thing that you wanted to take the
time-lapse movie off but that's not what
I've been thinking about for the most
part mostly in these
[Music]
away from the internet what I've been
thinking about is how different life is
here without really being very different
at all I've got a friend who's about to
go to the Congo to teach digital media
to Congolese people awesome idea that is
going to be a very different life this
now the difference just doesn't have the
Internet
that's the only real difference but it's
just different enough for me to realize
that most of the people in the world
live lives that are nothing like the
life I live and I spend literally no
time thinking about those people's lives
or why they love living them and how
they as people have been shaped by those
lives that I know nothing about John you
and I talked a lot about understanding
other people complexly
then we go and we spend like ten hours a
day in front of a computer screen and
that's the minimum how do you understand
people complexly if you know nothing
about them what we really need to do is
spend as much time as possible with
people who are as different from us as
possible what we do is the exact
opposite of that because it's much more
comfortable and much easier to
understand people complexly when they
are very similar to us because we can
just take us and then add and subtract
certain things so here I am living in a
world that might as well be the 1950s
with people who sit around and talk
about the good old days when children
never got abducted and apples tasted
better and meat was good for you and we
always knew who the bad guys were and
what I know for real is that those days
are old but they aren't any more good
than the days we've got today what they
are is something that I will never be
able to understand and something that's
shaped millions of Americans and that's
why I have such a hard time
understanding so many of the people in
America nevermind the rest of the world
it's also the reason why their way of
life is to me about as stressful as it
is relaxing to them so to be honest how
am I ever gonna understand people
complexly if I don't occasionally spend
a few days away from that technological
teeth that is my home my work my fun my
play and of course my soapbox and thank
you for standing around my soapbox for
the last four minutes John you will see
me tomorrow with some decidedly less
serious and more internet inspired stuff
in a video that I filmed last week
because I was prepared I'm like I am now
I totally didn't even bring my firewire
cable which is why I'm on
eyesight camera proving to you that you
can make a good blog with the iSight
camera
[Music]